good morning believe nation today's
message is be driven over to you
Shakira you know I grew up in Colombia
and Colombia is a developing country
where a lot of people don't have access
to the most basic needs and where
education is considered a luxury
unfortunately because we all know that
education is a birthright and and I just
grew up frustrated seeing seeing how
many people weren't able to to realize
their own dreams you know when I was
eight years old my dad underwent an
economic crisis the financial crisis you
know he lost his business and we
struggled economically for many years we
lost our car we lost our furniture and I
remember vividly the day I walked in my
house and all the furniture was gone
because my head my dad had to pay his
debt and it was quite well shocking for
me you know I was 8 7 8 years old and
and when I saw this I was so frustrated
I my dad I'm so upset with my parents
because I couldn't understand how they
did so poorly in business you know I'm
like why why you know I couldn't I
couldn't get it and my dad and my mom
took me to the park where they showed me
other kids my age sniffing glue they
were orphans they had no one to watch
after them and they were barefoot and
they were abandoned to their unlock and
it probably left such an impression in
my impressionable mind at that age that
I remember that day and I remember that
I made myself a promise I said I said to
myself Shakira
you have to succeed because you have to
you have to ride in a car again one day
you know you you have to get your own
car someday
and and I wanted to vindicate my parents
socially and economically and I also
wanted to someday do something for those
kids who I saw that day in the park so
as soon as I had my first big success
with PS Descalzos which was my third
album I decided to establish my own
Foundation and do my own contribution to
the change even if it was going to be a
small one but I wanted to be active and
that's how it all started you know going
through my own a financial struggle and
the struggle of my family and
understanding that the one thing that I
never lacked was care protection and in
education and that's probably what made
me thrive in life having a why is so
important to accomplish in any big thing
especially having success in business
you have to know why you're doing
something if you're gonna continue to
many people start a business just
because they're trying to make money you
may be in debt you may need to pay your
bills so I'm gonna start a company to do
it it's not a strong enough why what
ends up happening for the people who are
just motivated by money what they do is
they start a company sometimes they'll
have success they'll make a little bit
of money just enough to pay their bills
and then they ease off the ease off the
throttle they stop pushing hard because
they paid off their bills until the
bills come again and then they work
harder and these people were motivated
by money are just living paycheck to
paycheck to paycheck to paycheck and
they never get the money they're after
you have to understand what it is that
you stand for and what big thing you're
trying to accomplish if you can't make
that connection to the work you're doing
every day guess what you're gonna stop
working you're not gonna put everything
you've got into it because there's no
strong why behind it when I look at my
first business I struggled a lot right I
was making $300 a month barely able to
survive and I told my partner that I
quit and you guys have heard the story a
couple times probably I told my partner
that I quit
and I woke up the next day and like I'm
not gonna be a quitter I need to see
this through I don't want to live the
rest of my life in regret I had a
situation the year before where there
was a moment that I regretted not taking
action when I should have I was afraid
and they have the courage so I didn't
take action and I took a picture that
moment I hung it on my wall as a
reminder to myself that the next time I
want to do something and I'm too afraid
to do it I have to go and take that
chance because the regret will eat you
up
because I can deal with it not working
out I can deal with the failure but I
can't deal with not knowing the
immediate pain of rejection or failure
sucks but it's nothing compared to the
lifetime of regret that you'll have
always looking back on that moment and
knowing you should have done something
so I went back to my company after that
first experience went back to my
business because I didn't want to leave
feeling like I could do a little bit
more I've got a little bit more in me I
didn't want to live with regret what's
your why if you are not getting up daily
and pounding on your business you don't
have a strong enough why so tap into it
what is it what are you staying for what
are you trying to build why is it so
important that it's a months for you to
go out and accomplish today and I would
put that into my daily routine you wake
up at least for me I need to reset every
day you wake up and start thinking about
why am i doing what I'm doing why am i
doing what I'm about to do today why is
it so important to me and if you can't
come up with an amazing reason you're
gonna mail in today you're just not
gonna work hard you're gonna do enough
to get by and you're gonna be one of
those people who lose paycheck to
paycheck to paycheck you want to
increase your standard of living you
want to increase the impact that you're
having on the world you want to increase
your level fulfillment and happiness
have a more important why so the
question today is what is your why leave
it down the comments below
super curious to find out I also want to
give a quick shout-out to Fikri Raman
thank you so much for picking up a cop
my book your one-word really really
really means a lot to me and I hope
you're enjoying the read so thank you
guys again for watching
I believe in you hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
events Press
[Music]
if you really have a drive and you
really put your heart and soul into
something you can really make anything
happen I'm a true believer in that so I
think that we hopefully we make people
believe that they can achieve the
American dream to just watch study us
and if you really are passionate and
driven you can get there my true feeling
is this no matter who you are no matter
what age you are no matter the time in
your life if you have a dream and you
have the drive you can make anything
happen and if you are ever feeling down
or feeling like you can't get over that
hump or you just have a bad day I play
this song and you remember this song
okay here it goes
I mean I grew up within hip-hop culture
you know that's that's what I was
immersed in like as a youth like that's
what I was surrounded by so naturally
that's you know what I gravitate
gravitated towards you know I mean if I
grew up somewhere else maybe I would
have wanted to play guitar like you know
sing folk songs or something but that
was just naturally what I gravitated to
because that was what I was surrounded
by that was my world I don't know I was
in the music you know some kids were in
the basketball I wasn't very good so you
know music was like I wasn't just like a
kid who just you know I don't know play
video games so just sat on computer all
day doing nothing just I mean I was like
a driven kid you know I mean so music
became like my like passion my vehicle
for you know I mean what I was you know
driven to do and naturally it was what I
was surrounded by you once at an
interview that your life is paranoia and
fear and you're just trying to not get
hit yeah is that still true yeah
anger and fear fear of failure drives me
paranoia of things going wrong around me
drives me I am driven by a lot of like
really kind of ugly
and so I have a lot of that in me and it
comes from a father who was terrifying
and teachers who yelled at me told me
I'd never be anything
and so I I descend from the sky and land
on things really hard and I go at
everything with that amount of fury and
I'm not saying I'm gonna hit anybody and
I'm not mad at you I'm quite happy to be
an answer any question to the best of my
ability but I go at everything like you
think I can't hey you want to try acting
y'all try acting
can you act No so let's go I've seen
something on okay you can act thank you
fares for losers I'd rather win